where we help the communities build latrines,
and we teach them to separate their animals from their living quarters
in order to reduce the fly population.
So we know how to tackle the disease.
But we need to know where it is.
And we do,
because a few years ago, Sightsavers led an incredible program
called the Global Trachoma Mapping Project.
It took us three years,
but we went through 29 countries,
and we taught local health workers to go district by district,
and they examined the eyelids of over two and a half million people.
And they used Android phones in order to download the data.
And from that, we were able to build a map
that showed us where the disease was.
Now, this is a very high-level map
that shows you which countries had a problem with trachoma.
And you may ask me, "Well, does this strategy actually work?"
Yes, it does.
This map shows you the progress that we've made to date.
The green countries believe they've already eliminated trachoma,
and they have either been through or are in the process of
having that validated by the WHO.
Countries in yellow have the money they need,
they have the resources to eliminate trachoma.
And some of them are really nearly there.
But the red countries, they don't have enough funding.
They cannot eliminate trachoma unless they get more.
And we're quite concerned, though, that the progress to date may stall.
So when we were talking to the Audacious ideas guys,
we asked ourselves:
If we really, really pushed ourselves over the next four or five years
and we had the money,
what do we think we could achieve?
Well, we believe that we can eliminate trachoma
in 12 African countries
and across the Americas
and all across the Pacific.
And we can make significant progress
in two countries which have the highest burden of the disease,
which is Ethiopia and Nigeria.
And in doing all of that,
we can leverage more than two billion dollars' worth of donated drugs.
(Applause)
Now, this map here shows you the impact that we'll have --
look how many countries are going green.
And there, you can see progress in Ethiopia and Nigeria.
Now, yes, there are some countries that are still red.
These are mainly countries which are in conflict --
places like Yemen, South Sudan -- where it's very difficult to work.
So, we have the team, the strategy and the map.
And we also have the relationships with the governments
so that we can make sure that our program is coordinated
with other disease-control programs,
so that we can be efficient.
Wouldn't it be amazing if we could do this?
We'd have trachoma on the run.
We would be on the home straight
to eliminate this disease from the whole world.
But before I finish, I just want to share with you
some words from the founder of Sightsavers,
a guy called Sir John Wilson.
Now, he was blinded at the age of 12.
And he said,
"People don't go blind by the million.
They go blind one by one."
And in the excitement of being able to say
we've got rid of trachoma for the whole country,
let's not forget that, actually, this is a devastating disease
that destroys the lives of individual people.
People like Twiba.
Now, I met Twiba last year in Tanzania.
She had had trachoma for as long as she could remember.
And a couple of months before I met her, she'd had the operation.
It's no exaggeration to say
that this had totally transformed her life.
We'd saved the sight that she had left, and she was free of pain.
She could sleep.
She could work, she could socialize.
And she said to me,
"I have my life back."
And it was impossible not to be moved by her story.
But there are so many Twibas.
I want to find all the Twibas,
and I don't want anyone to go blind in agony anymore.
Now, you know, there are so many intractable problems in this world.
But this is not one of them.
This is something that we can solve.
And we can ensure
that kids like this can grow up free from the fear of trachoma.
So, for the sake of kids like this,
and for the sake of people like Twiba,
let's get rid of trachoma.
Do you think we can?
Well, yeah, if we really, really want to.
Yes, we can.
So thank you.
(Applause)